when a hurricane is approaching
safety of life and the preservation of
livelihoods is most
important we should take heed
fill five gallon buckets and other
containers with water prior to the storm
you'll need it to water transplants in
the greenhouse if you have lost
power mulch as many bare roots as
possible before the storm
mulching will help prevent erosion and
wind damage
and will also minimize soil splashing
into the crop
canopy which can cause disease rib
mature crops such as tomatoes and melons
because they will split after heavy
rains pick coconuts and consider
harvesting cut flowers
right before the storm as they will be
easily damaged by rain
and wind fortify any field trellises so
you don't lose the crops they are
supporting
wherever possible unhang trellis plants
and place them to lay flat on the ground
make sure tractors and other equipment
and supplies are secured
don't leave market baskets picking
crates dip tape
or irrigation pipes in the field or lane
around where they can become missiles in
high winds
or get washed away by flood waters and
stock upon gas for generators and other
needed farm equipment
remember this is the hurricane season
and we should be prepared a message
brought to you by the ministry of
agriculture fisheries
physical planning natural resources and
cooperatives